[Arabic recitation]
chapters regarding wudu,
the sub chapter of the instances in
which it is preferred that a person make
wudu. Things that it is preferred that a
person have wudu to do, or instances
when it is preferred for a person to
make wudu.
The author has mentioned nine.
We've read together thus far eight.
Let's see if we can
recall
any of them.
In the instances in which it is
obligatory to have wudu,
we mentioned
how many things? Three. Person must
Three things you have to have wudu to
do.
Number one,
salah. Number two,
mushaf Quran. Number three,
al-tawaf. Okay.
Let's go with
ma yustahabbu lahu al-wudu. Where wudu
Instances in which wudu is preferred.
Eight of them.
And no, okay.
Dhikr Allah.
Mhm?
To eat. Mhm,
you're missing a part there.
okay. So, if a person eats something
that has been cooked on an open flame,
Najmuddin mentions eating for the person
in janabah.
If a person is in janabah,
then it is the sunnah to make wudu
to eat, or drink,
or to sleep, or to
have intercourse or relations again.
Okay?
That's four.
Number five.
Before every salat, correct.
And when we say before every salat,
well, what does that mean? Does that
mean that let's say I'm going to pray
wudu.
So, I make wudu, and then I make two
rakat, and then I go back and make wudu,
and then make the fard, and then go back
and make wudu, and then make the sunnah,
and then go back and make wudu, and then
make the sunnah. Is that what's
intended? No. Meaning every
continuous
continuous time of prayer, every
session of salat, whether that is
obligatory or
preferred.
So, for instance,
a person is in salat
as long as he remains in the place that
he made salat,
in the masjid, right?
So, let's say right now
we just made salat.
We finished salat. We're still in the
same place. We're still in the masjid.
We are still in salat.
If we waited until the sun came up and
wanted to make two rakat before we left
the masjid, would it be the sunnah to
make wudu again?
No, because we're still in salat.
It would be the sunnah to make wudu
again if we broke off,
went about our business, and then
decided to make salat again, etc.
Tayyib, that is five.
[Arabic recitation]
After breaking wudu. Anytime a person
breaks wudu, right?
That's six.
We got two more.
If a person vomits, after vomiting. Very
good.
One more that we mentioned. You guys are
missing it.
It's so obvious.
Soon as I say it, you're going to be
like, "Wow, that was so obvious."
Before we listen. Very good.
At the start of every
bathing. At the start of every listen.
Okay.
The ninth instance
in which it is preferred that a person
make wudu
is
from carrying a janazah, from carrying a
dead body.
[Silence]
This narration has been collected by
Imam Ahmad and others.
The prophet
says,
"Whoever bathes a body, then he is to
bathe
after doing so. And whoever carries a
body is to make wudu after doing so."
Now,
apparently,
just that statement on its own, on its
face,
would articulate that it is obligatory.
It's a command, right? If you carry
body, then make wudu. If you bathe the
body, then
make ghusl.
However, there are other narrations
which articulate
that it is not necessary.
Rather, it is only and merely
preferred.
[Silence]
So, there's a narration collected by
al-Hakim al-Naysaburi on the authority
of Ibn Abbas in which the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam says,
"There is no
responsibility or obligation to bathe
after bathing
a body, after bathing your dead,
because your dead are neither filthy in
themselves.
So, rather, it is enough for you to
merely wash your hands after doing so.
So, here we have one narration where the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam says,
"You don't have to, you just you should
wash your hands." And another narration
that says, "Make wudu if you carry and
make ghusl if you bathe a dead body."
So, when we harmonize these two
narrations, we put them together, we
understand that it is preferable, it is
preferred that a person make wudu after
carrying a body, make ghusl after
bathing one.
So, with that, we have finished this
chapter, and tomorrow, inshallah, we
will begin with the rulings
on
wiping over the footwear.
Right? Wiping over the socks or shoes or
what have you, which is a whole can of
worms. It's exhausting for me to talk
about it, but
we will, inshallah, take it bit by bit
and try to work it out.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]